من جديد خرج الالاف في العاصمه الالمانيه
برلين للمطالبه بوقف فوري لاطلاق النار في
غزه هذا المشهد تكرر اليوم في العديد من
المدن الالمانيه التي تطالب حكومتها
بالضغط على اسرائيل وتحاول ايضا كل هؤلاء
يحاولون تغيير المواقف الحكوميه التي
يقولون انها داعمه لاسرائيل ولذلك رغم
الاج والبارده رغم اجواء اعياد الميلاد
يصرون على الاحتجاج ويقولون انهم سيواصلون
الخروج الى الشوارع الالمانيه للاحتجاج
لايصال صوتهم لتكرار نفس المطلب الوقف
الفوري لاطلاق النار
وادخال المساعدات
الى غزه هذه المظاهره هي الاكبر هنا اليوم
في برلين ولكن مثل كولونيا وشتوتغارت
بدورها شهدت خروج الالاف دعما لغزه وشج
ايضا للمواقف الحكوميه التي يقولون ان
انها تختلف تماما عن موقف الشارع الالماني
الذي يدعم بشكل كبير الوقف الفوري لاطلاق
النار وانهاء هذه الحرب ايمنه سبيره
الجزيره برلين